this video is sponsored by waymo
[Music]
what's up guys i'm jason silva and i'm
immensely passionate about
technology being used to overcome our
limitations at its very
best technology allows us to transcend
our
limits to overcome our boundaries and on
this
note there's hardly more exciting
technology than fully autonomous
driving technology we're talking about
mobility for
all we're talking about a company called
waymo waymo is an autonomous driving
technology company that has created the
world's
smartest driver the waymo driveway
now why is this important aside from the
fact that this is fully autonomous
driving technology we live
in a world my friends where 1.3 million
people a year
die from traffic related accidents 50
percent
of which are pedestrians cyclists and
motorcyclists all right so this is 50
million
injuries this is a horrible thing 94 of
traffic accidents are human
error human beings we are
limited we have blind spots we have
perceptual limitations we lack
perfect situational awareness
[Music]
leveraging advances in machine learning
and computer
vision and artificial intelligence we
have literally with the waymo
driver a level of situational awareness
level of
prediction a level of mapping of the
environment that is
unsurpassed something we've never seen
before as arthur c clarke
said any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic and the waymo driver is
indistinguishable my friends
from magic the experience unsurpassed
20 million miles driven on roads
across the country 20 billion miles in
simulated
environments we're talking a
game-changing revolution the waymo
driver is going to change the world
now i had the opportunity to have a
conversation with some of the genius
minds
behind waymo and behind the waymo driver
we
had a conversation i had a chance to ask
a couple of questions
how does it feel for all of you guys to
be
creating something that sounds like
science fiction
made reality like a seeing
perceiving predicting autonomous
entity that can safely transport us
when i came to waymo i thought this is
going to become real
this is happening i could see it
happening and i wrote
it was sci-fi and i felt that you know
that
all of the work we were doing it was
worth something i sat in it and then the
car
just drove us all over no driver it
navigated all the complexities that you
could see
um and i think that's that's where we
are all in this together that's why
there is we have so much energy at wemo
because we know we are doing something
that is
truly going to change it will be
transformative for all of us
you know i really think the the entry
point
here is capturing the imagination
of the passenger maybe an adult first
meets it with apprehension and fear
first before they get curious whereas a
child
might be curious first before they get
nervous
um you're exactly right that difference
between
kids and adults for instance you feel
the vehicle hesitating when you might
hesitate
and and being decisive when you your
muscle memory feels like it would be
decisive
you could feel the vehicle's hesitation
getting less and less
and now yeah it legitimately feels like
it's doing what my body would do
from muscle memory the three different
systems for
providing i guess the situational
awareness the lidar the vision and the
radar
do they all kind of feed into a central
hub or like feed into each other so that
it's
comparing the reading from the lidar and
the vision and the radar to like
cross check and error check certain
readings like is that what makes it
compound in its accuracy that those
things work together
yeah you're exactly okay and so what
you'll notice for later on when we look
at the demo of the trip
what we actually do for the user is we
even show you the three-dimensional
world that we are building together
based on all of these signals together
we'll show you where we see a car
whether it's close or far away
not
of available and the amount of mapping
and scanning of the environment with all
of these three systems working together
plus the heart the software component
already that to me
seems like a case to get rid of human
drivers tomorrow
considering that over 90 percent of
accidents are caused by human error like
over 90
now as you can see it was a fruitful
conversation and again my vision is one
in which we use technology to overcome
problems we use technology to extend our
reach we use technology to give mobility
for all and on this note i couldn't be
more excited about waymo
and the waymo driver thanks guys cheers